So yesterday, despite the fact that the mayor
of Kenosha, Wisconsin, said, don't come here,
the governor of Wisconsin said don't come
here.
Donald Trump forced his way to Wisconsin and
had a roundtable event.
Now, later, I'm going to tell you about some
of these.
So it almost makes sense to call them crisis
actors that Trump.
Brought in for this event.
But before I get to that, I want to actually
play some clips for you of this completely
toxic and pathetic roundtable that Donald
Trump did, which he started by saying everybody
maybe should look at taking their masks off.
Take a look at this.
It's a great honor.
If you feel more comfortable, you'll see a
couple of words.
You might want to take the mask off.
Otherwise, you're going to leave.
Either way, you want the how fast you took
that.
So, again, the language of.
Pandemic, we beat that.
That's over, we got past the pandemic already,
taking masks off as something people may want
to do here.
We saw it with fifteen hundred people at his
convention speech.
No Cauvin tests, no masks, no social distancing.
We're continuing to see this attitude of the
pandemic is in the past.
That's not really a thing anymore.
Trump then again, using this analogy about
when police sometimes choke.
And you would imagine that after everything
that's happened, including George, Floyd,
Floyd, and including the debate over chokeholds,
maybe Trump would have some other metaphor
to use here.
But no.
And he also points out that he feels very
safe in Wisconsin right now.
We can't be threatening them with their pensions
are going to be taken away.
Their jobs is going to be taken away.
Everything's going to be taken away.
They're going to be living a bad life.
If if they utter an incorrect word, you can't
do it.
We have to have our law enforcement.
We cherish our law enforcement.
We wouldn't be here without our law enforcement.
Even me.
I'm here today.
I feel so safe.
And you went through hell just a few days
ago.
But I feel so safe.
I better be safe.
But we're all safe and we're safe because
of law enforcement.
And we honor you.
And I will say this.
We have to condemn the dangerous anti police
rhetoric.
It's getting more and more.
It's very unfair.
You have some bad apples.
We all know that.
And those will be taken care of through the
system.
And nobody is going to be easy on him either.
And you have people that joke.
They're under tremendous.
I said it yesterday.
I said it last night.
They're under tremendous pressure.
So Trump kind of floated this idea in that
strange interview with Laura Ingram that he
did on Sunday night.
I believe it was.
Or don't we?
I actually was Monday night where he said,
you know, sometimes police choke.
Sort of like when you miss a three, put a
three foot putt in golf, which was not the
most fine-tuned indelicate analogy that maybe
he could have done.
And particularly in light of George Floyd
and everything else, choking is probably not
the word I would be using.
Attorney General William Barr, one of the
most extreme sycophants that we've ever seen,
hold the position of attorney general, traveled
to Kenosha with Donald Trump and insists that
the violence that happened after the Jacob
Blake shooting was not a legitimate response
to a police shooting.
Take a look at this that erupted shortly after
the shooting is simply not a legitimate response
to a police shooting.
And the looting and the arson were unacceptable.
And as it progressed, it became more and more
distant from the issue of racial justice.
It was violence for violence sake.
So, again, I don't think there is anything
wrong with saying looting and arson are not
acceptable forms of protest.
There are people who think that they are.
I happen to disagree and I think that they
are counterproductive forms of protest, more
importantly.
But notice that William Barr didn't condemn
Kyle Rittenhouse, who has been charged with
homicide.
Trump didn't condemn Kyle Rittenhouse.
And in fact, increasingly the right is making
him out to be a hero.
So it's not so much about Barr is wrong by
criticizing arson.
It's that just focusing on arson by leftists
is number one.
Completely out of sync with what is actually
happening on the ground.
Number two, ignoring more than half of the
story.
Donald Trump was asked whether he thinks police
should wear body cameras.
This is super interesting because what we're
seeing time and again is Trump is devoid of
substance.
Trump is unable to discuss substance and actual
policy.
He just can't do it.
And here Trump is asked about body cameras.
He just hammers and haws.
He literally gives no answer because he can't
figure out your body cameras.
Should every police officer in the United
States wearing body body cam?
Well, that's Chris Christie.
Let me build into that question.
This is what it looks like when your brain
is mush. Trump is unable, unable to discuss
actual policy substance, even when it's a
simple question, just bails out and asks somebody
else to help him with the answer.
There was another instance of this, an attempt
to get Donald Trump to talk about substance.
The question was very simple question.
Do you believe systemic racism is a problem
in this country?
And Donald Trump just doesn't answer and says,
oh, we should be talking about protests.
We're focusing on violent actions.
But there've been countless nonviolent protests
here in Wisconsin and across the.
This summer, people calling for an end to
systemic racism, do you believe systemic racism
is a problem in this country?
Well, you know, you just keep getting back
to the opposite subject.
We should talk about the kind of violence
that we've seen in Portland and here and other
places.
It's tremendous violence.
You always get to the other side.
Well, what do you think about this or that?
The fact is that we've seen tremendous violence
and we will put it out very, very quickly
if given the chance.
And that's what this is all about.
I keep hearing about peaceful protests.
I hear it about everything.
And then I come into an area like this and
I see the town is burned down.
I mean, you look at Minneapolis, he just cannot
answer it or he won't answer it.
The question was not about violence in Portland.
The question was simply, do you think systemic
racism exists?
This is maybe breaking news to some people.
You can simultaneously hold the beliefs that
arson is bad and that there is reason for
people to be upset because of systemic racism
in the United States.
You can hold that view.
You can now whether Trump holds it or doesn't
or is not willing to say it.
That's a different question.
There was a second attempt at basically the
same question about systemic racism and systemic
change.
Trump still unable to answer it questions.
But my question is, are the same again, the
peaceful protests that have now been going
have to speak up to the peaceful protests
that have happened.
You've acknowledged some of them are peaceful.
They're calling for structural change.
Mr. Blake was shot seven times in the values.
You believe that there is a need for structural
change.
What is your message?
Well, I think people are calling for structural
change.
And then you can take the people of Kenosha
that aren't here and that you won't see and
that aren't protesting.
But they want change also.
They want to see law and order.
That's the change they want.
They want a loan order just cannot or will
not acknowledge or or even answer questions
about systemic racism.
And Aaron PA on Twitter asked a good question,
which is, what's the point of these trips
to places like Kenosha?
He flies in, meets with groups of carefully
selected sycophants, holds a roundtable where
everybody praises him, and then flies back
to D.C. Aaron arguing on Twitter yesterday
that it's a complete waste of time and money.
I would say something else.
It's actually counterproductive when the local
officials don't want you there.
Remember that the mayor of Kenosha said, don't
come here.
The governor of Wisconsin said, don't come
here.
The owner of a business that burned down refused
to participate in the photo ops, and they
brought in someone else to be photographed
with Trump as if they were the owners of this
business.
I'm going to talk about that a little bit
later.
But in the meantime, remember that you can
follow us on Instagram at David Pakman show
and remember that this program is mostly funded,
mostly funded by individual members who sign
up at Join Pacman.
If you're enjoying the programing, consider
supporting us with a membership.
It's quick, it's easy, and it takes under
a minute to sign up at Join Patman.
Dot com.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.